non sono un digital natives il piace del
film digitali migranti e amo
l'innovazione ma inseguono del contempo
miglioramento continuo
ma lo faccio con la stessa passione con
la quale da piccolo mi piaceva a
guardare le nuvole in cielo muoversi in
quei giorni di primavera quando il tempo
non è stabile è il vento spira veloce il
miglioramento continuo
è una grandezza paradossale libera più
energia di quanta ne assorbe il re mento
continuo un abitudine mentale
il giorno che ti accorgi che non stai
seguendo avvertì che ti manca qualcosa
il miglioramento continuo
è una salita continua verso livelli
superiori di equilibrio più vicini
all'eccellenza e ad ogni passaggio ad
ogni ciclo meglio si rinnova il definire
un obiettivo pensare alla alle azioni
potenzialmente bloccanti definire
attività prospettare un acuto atteso e
confrontare quanto ottenuto con quanto
pensato e da quel gap che si origina
ecco inizia un altro ciclo digita
trasformation si pone oggi come come un
ascensore capace di raccogliere il
miglioramento continuo e portarlo ad un
livello superiore dove la tecnologia
abilitante può attivare l'organizzazione
in maniera esponenziale
quello che accade è un cambio di
paradigma da lineare a esponenziale e in
un contesto in cui è la competenza
organizzativa
il primo fattore della trasformazione e
non mi riferisco solamente a procedure
standard best practice ma molto di più
quel vissuto quotidiano di
organizzazione
fatto di quelle informazioni e
sottotraccia fatto di quelle decisioni
che si prendono a pilota automatico
inserito
ebbene è in questo contesto che la
tecnologia può agire come una leva e
favorire l'emersione di di un nuovo
ecosistema unico sistema in cui la parte
sottostante presente funzionante
stratificata e capace di far fiorire
qualcosa di nuovo
quello che emerge è un ecosistema che mi
piace definire
ap si attiva un processo nel quale la
competenza ma anche i dati le
informazioni che sono annidate
nell'organizzazione vengono analizzate
suddivise in pacchetti logici
interdipendenti e vengono convertiti in
un codice un codice che alla base di un
applicazione ma l'applicazione non è il
punto d'arrivo
l'app è lo strumento per generare una
sorta di realtà aumentata in cui modo di
lavorare tradizionale consueto viene
arricchito e attivato da queste nuove
metodologie ed è un processo questo di
convertire una competenza in un'app che
è poi anche un asset tangibile che nelle
poi le persone continuano ad essere
estremamente importanti sono la parte
più importante quelle che si attivano
sono di dei cortocircuiti organizzativi
nei quali smettiamo di dover dipendere
da cui complicatissimi files legati tra
di loro e non mai aggiornati molto
spesso excel in cui smettiamo di dover
ricordare in maniera maniacale quello
che è accaduto quel giorno a quella
talora ed entriamo in un nuovo ambiente
nel quale ci sono quattro dimensioni
fondamentali la connettività la
condivisione
il real time e l'inclusività la
connettività ci deriva dagli strumenti
mobile che oggi abbiamo praticamente in
mano per dieci ore al giorno
la condivisione al suo ambiente da
lezione in quello che il social media in
real time al suo clock in quello che la
notifica tormento alcune volte delle
nostre vite e l'esclusività è legata al
fatto che non esistono praticamente
barriere d'ingresso unico sistema up pro
x che trae origine da quella che è
un'esperienza maturata costantemente poi
rinnovata dei cippi di miglioramento
continuo attingere una sorgente
praticamente inesauribile e da
proiezioni di sviluppo praticamente
illimitate non solo ma proprio perché è
la esperienza di utilizzo che ne
favorisce la sua il suo sviluppo
finisce per assumere uno sviluppo
modulare in cui ogni applicazione che
viene aggiunta si appoggia
sull'esistente e fornisce l'interfaccia
a quella che arriva dopo vi voglio
provare a condurre per un attimo ad
osservare insieme a me quello che può
essere una metodologia il col sistema up
e di faccia entrare nel mondo delle
operations mondo nel quale il
miglioramento continua innovazione
coesistono si intrecciano e di bordo
nello specifico un processo produttivo
fatto di team diversi che cooperano
insieme uomo macchina e allo stesso un
comune obiettivo
nel momento in cui un problema emerge in
un team di lavoro avere a disposizione
un app consente di fare ad esempio che
cosa consente di attivare il
miglioramento continuo in scala
esponenziale
perché immediatamente posso raccogliere
questo problema in maniera evidente una
foto un video e lo posso condividere in
real time con il resto dei partecipanti
al processo
in questo modo tutti quanti sono e real
time cortocircuitati e tutti possono
lavorare per la ricerca della causa e
per la definizione di una soluzione
correttiva o preventiva ma quello che
accade di estremamente potente e che si
tiene una galleria di problema soluzione
problema soluzione è questa galleria
alimenta l'organizzazione e ne favorisce
la sua evoluzione e lo fa in tempi
rapidissimi di c.da trasformation a due
ingredienti fondamentali la tecnologia
per abilitare e le persone per guidare e
in questo contesto è estremamente chiave
il ruolo di direttore d'orchestra per
riuscire appunto a raccogliere quello
che idee progetti che emergono dal basso
e coniugarli armonizzarli con quella che
la direzione gli ambiti i tempi le
priorità che derivano più propriamente
di una road map e volgendo verso la
chiusura del mio intervento
vi invito a prendervi cura della
consapevolezza digitale delle vostre
organizzazioni non datelo per scontato
solo in funzione della intensità e
frequenza con cui ne parliamo attivate
dei processi di digital governance con
le vostre persone provate a fargli
capire quello che può essere l'impatto
nello specifico da loro attività di
questa trasformazione
fateli incontrare il mondo delle startup
perché loro sono le prime che hanno
capito quanto sia importante pensare in
grande e agire nell'immediato favorite
la crescita di un ambiente nel quale la
sperimentazione il provare rischiando
anche di fallire si è vissuta come un
valore positivo e non come una colpa e
inoltre sappiate accompagnare a quello
che il flusso botton a promuovendo
insieme proattività e creatività e per
chiudere technology to enable people to
lead e
[Applauso]